[Music]
all right jimmy so we're both creators
yeah both make videos i think we have a
lot in common but i also think there are
a lot of big differences between our
channels and our workflows and how we do
things you don't bury yourself alive
so i got 20 questions for you let's do
it all right first one what's the first
app you open on your phone in the
morning i love how we just jumped right
into this um definitely twitter twitter
yeah okay i wouldn't recommend but
that's what i do if you're ever at like
a i don't know barber shop or in the
back of an uber or something like that
and somebody asks you what you do
how do you answer that question oh well
if i'm in the back of an uber i lie i
just said work at mcdonald's because i
you know i don't want to drop me off in
my house and be like yo i know where a
youtuber lives right true do you have
like like there's usually follow-up
questions you ever like say what you do
and then have to sort of explain it yeah
so i guess i typically just describe it
as i like to give away money while
torturing myself and occasionally
torturing my friends and then just doing
whatever random weird things pop in my
head that's gonna get some follow-up
questions yeah for sure i just say i'm a
video producer and usually that sort of
cafe you're basically no you're the
video producer that decides what tech
everyone in america buys that's what you
are i mean you're too humble to say that
but like half the time i watch his
videos and i just leave and go buy stuff
so we're sitting here in uh part of the
semi deconstructed squid game set from
the video you did on top of a
bunch of money you're sitting on about
two hundred thousand dollars we haven't
sent it to them yet it's casual um you
said before in a video that you you
didn't tell your parents when you
started making your channel and then you
found it at like 10 000 subscribers
same i didn't tell my parents about it
they found it when they did find it how
do they react and like what's the
difference between then when they found
it and yeah when all this is going on
well my mom was like oh my gosh she's
not crazy because she would always think
i was just talking to random people in
my room or just like talking to myself
when i was like recording videos so she
she kind of had a hunch and then she's
like but why and she's like your your
grades suck can we like start spend more
time on school less on videos and i was
like no i want to spend less time on
school and more time on videos so my mom
just wanted what was best for me but it
was pretty brutal at the start because i
was doing bad in school and i literally
would just stay up all night making
youtube videos but then
i think there was a moment where
we did a brand deal that was basically
more than her entire salary and that was
kind of when it switched and she was
like you know what you keep doing you
actually how about can i join you yeah
mom come join us now she loves it
obviously you know not because she's
money hungry she just didn't want me to
end up you know working at a fast food
restaurant which you know i mean if this
didn't work out i don't i don't know
what else i would have ended up doing
was that the money comfy sitting on 200
i've never sat on 200 grand so i didn't
have like here put your feet over there
now you'll be on there
okay 400 grand is that more comfy that
is more confident
don't rob us we have security
okay so you've counted to a hundred
thousand yes you said pewdiepie a
hundred thousand times i did it and
logan paul a hundred thousand times you
uh
completed a mile in the world's largest
shoes yep
what's the hardest challenge you've ever
done physically speaking the hardest
challenge uh surprisingly none of those
is actually when i buried myself alive
that was yeah i buried myself live for
50 hours i'm sure footage on screen it
was it was brutal because i'll be honest
coffins aren't comfortable and my back
was hurting and like 30 hours in i was
like i almost got out like even just
thinking about it makes me almost tear
up it was so painful on my back i feel
like you should collaborate with david
blaine at some point because all of his
stunts are somewhere on the borderline
of like how much can you actually
physically tolerate yeah that spectacle
is just as weirdly enough when i did
that we were in contact and then since
then we haven't talked but david if you
see this please let's do something
okay so if you had to guess
how many cameras are on the entire
campus for all of the channels oh god
you run ballpark you have to put in a
number well so there's videos like last
take handoff lamborghini where we put 50
people's hands on a lamborghini and in
that video we had to get like 50 of
these so we could zoom in and monitor
every hand and then if you turn the
camera there's uh videos where we do
hide and see sometimes with dozens of
people and so they each need a handheld
and then other videos we need like 50
gopros i mean we're probably up to like
250 300 cameras but
i was going to guess it was higher i
think i guess like i'm trying to be
conservative but yeah yeah it's uh it's
crazy but it's not like we're just
buying them to buy them it's just like
certain videos literally need like 50 to
60 cameras at certain times i just like
we just buy cameras and they sit here
and then when we need them we just grab
them that's the way to go that's the way
to go yeah i personally i don't like
like super high quality cameras i prefer
to look a little more amateur so i've
been using like these g7xs and like
average stuff for like a very long time
24 or 30 fps
a 30. okay yeah there it is yeah 24 is
like
your your career is fading like you're
you know you're you're trying to get
into movies and some of that that never
works kidding i hope you don't do 24. i
do 30. okay
okay so i read somewhere i think you
said you've gone through a dictionary
and would just like pick random words to
see if you can find good video ideas in
there it works actually better than you
would think you still do that yeah yeah
so basically it's not just a dictionary
it's you you want to take in inspiration
and then see what pops in your head so
say a random word anywhere something you
don't think i will think you're gonna
say
mannequins okay we'll just make his
pipes okay so can can a million
mannequins stop a car can uh ten
thousand mannequins stop a tank right or
uh what happened i hate to make them all
the same but what if you put a million
mannequins on train tracks and try to
hit it with the train what happens yeah
it seems like something you could pull
off i
the hard part is like what makes it a
good like compelling video because
exactly people will be curious but what
makes it really good is a challenge well
and that's the thing but the point is
you you take in random inspiration you
see what pops in your head you write
them down and then usually one out of
every 100 is good and so that's why i
like to flip to the dictionary all right
so you know how spotify does that rap
thing every year where they'll show you
like all the artists and yeah you listen
to the most yeah if youtube did a
wrapped for you oh my gosh who would be
the most viewed channels that you watch
marquez bradley marquez brown oh
that's nice but who else
hmm
i'm gonna need like 10 seconds to think
take your time
you have to build your own raft this is
something i think they should actually
do by the way i agree i mean it's
obvious i don't know why they don't
youtube are screwing up i mean 90 of
people watch this won't even know these
channels but i love wendover production
polymatter
like people that just make videos like
it sounds dumb but like why uh global
shipping is easier than manufacturing
domestically or or like things like that
or like um what sort of edu splainer
type yeah exactly or like mark rover
veritasium i love learning things
because it's you know i'm not helping
myself here but i i don't like when i
spend a couple hours on youtube and i
don't really walk away with much so i
try to like really watch and click on
videos that teach me stuff so when i do
go on youtube it's like all videos that
i learned all right so i remember when
the first youtube channel hit a million
subscribers fred right it was a huge
deal it was for it i was gonna ask you
if you knew but of course you knew yeah
and then i remember the first one to hit
10 million i don't know that one ray ray
william johnson smosh oh that's right
yeah 10 million and then obviously
pewdiepie got to 100 million and it's
just crazy scale and just keeps getting
bigger and bigger yeah you've said
before your goal is to hit 100 million
subscribers yeah i feel like you have a
pretty good shot at making that happen
we're basically there yeah on the way
what how do you set goals for yourself
as a creator for your channel yeah
assuming you do hit 100 million do you
set another goal what exactly i got it i
love this question so back in the day my
goals used to be very subscriber based
or view based but one thing i've learned
and i think you've probably learned this
as well it's like
everything you want as a youtube creator
every freaking goal you want to hit
whether it be subscribers you want to
hit a million or 10 million or whatever
will come if you just make the best
videos possible so my goal and this is
what it will be until the day i die is
to make the best youtube videos possible
and so if my hypothetical goal was 300
million subscribers in 10 years that
will happen if i just make the best
videos possible my goal is to get 50
million views of video that will happen
if i just make the best whatever it is
you know just focus on making the best
videos possible and all these other
vanity arbitrary metrics will just fall
into play i don't mean that in an
arrogant way but that's just kind of
like the mindset you have to have like
go hard and believe in yourself you know
okay so you've had a lot of interesting
ideas for videos yes i wonder how many
of them you've probably said this before
but how many of them do you scrap
after you started them before they're
done oh gosh um
so
probably one out of every four videos
being a filming end up getting scrapped
because like i'll give you an example
right climbing a wall with plungers
seems like a cool idea yeah and then you
get hundreds of plungers you get the
strongest plungers in the world you hire
engineers and you realize you can't
climb a wall with plungers and so then
it gets scrapped or you know we made the
world's largest cookie and we were going
to try to eat it but then you know you
get in the weeds and you're like wait a
minute eating that much sugar is
probably not good for you yeah and so
then it's like ops kill it um and so
it's one of those things where you know
i'm 23 i haven't done a lot of these
things and so while i'm doing it i learn
stuff and i'm like oh
that's not what i thought okay this is a
quick one why do you have the world's
largest iphone and i don't um i don't
know i just saw it on ebay look cool
is it it does it works
it works i'm so glad this isn't my town
i thought you just docked me
comment down below if you think he
should switch his normal phone to the
world's largest iphone for a month and
vlog it i think that would be such a
good video a month a month give him give
me a week i'll do a week two weeks take
her or leave it right if he doesn't so
here's one how do you decide
what to say yes to because that's what
you have the ability if you want to pick
up the phone and make any video you want
happen i mean there's yeah that's being
built for the most insane ideas i've
ever seen yeah
how do you set because most of it is how
you decide on the guess yeah well so
video specifically it's uh it's pretty
simple what what makes the best video
possible i mean like i hate to keep
coming back to this point but that's all
that matters what makes the best video
possible what will people enjoy the most
what's something original unique blah
blah you know that they've never seen
before and
that's that's kind of really yeah
yeah i mean like it's not money i don't
care to make money i literally look at
this you think this is profitable on a
youtube channel it's not money it's not
really time or effort it's really just
whatever's the best video that's what i
want to do
and i think as long as that's your
standard like everything else just falls
into place as a youtuber so i feel like
the squid games video was sort of a
a long time in the making or almost like
a master which by the way if you hear
background noises because they're
tearing down the sets of squid game so
we're literally in the middle of it i
don't know that's we're in one of the
squid game rooms as they're tearing down
the other ones i wanted to move around
it's my fault but uh do you have a new
grail video that you want to make sure i
do some like super high-end production
that you've been dreaming of making that
you can't wait to yeah so i basically i
want to take everything i learned from
squid game and apply it to this other
idea but if i told you i legit would
have to kill you okay tell me i'll bleep
it out okay so basically i want to do
do you think it could be bigger than
squid game though
i think it could yeah it depends on when
you do it but yes yeah i mean it's gonna
take like six months yeah bet okay make
sure he blurs that it'll be a really
long bleep
all right i'm a reviewer but i gotta ask
you yeah for a little review can you
review youtube give me a rating of the
whole platform on a scale from one
attempt uh i mean i'm incredibly biased
uh a hundred out of ten because it
changed my life and gave me everything i
ever wanted well see that's dangerous
because youtube needs a little bit of
competition needs a little bit of like
reasoning i don't know i'm pretty happy
i think things are fine youtube gets rid
of the dislike counter on all videos
yeah they make decisions sometimes are a
little bit head scratchers do you feel
like well first of all what do you think
of the dislike counter disappearing i
see that's where it's one of those
things where i don't know if there's a
right answer because i do know that
people were you know targeting certain
groups of people or races of people and
bombing them with dislikes or using it
to abuse people and there were services
where you could buy a bunch so
in a way it was being used to silence
people and harassment but they're also
good ways it's a good signal to show
videos crappy or there's mention of
information and so i don't know i i lean
towards i think dislikes aren't that
good overall but i also see why they had
to get rid of it because you know it's
one of those tough things where i think
no matter what there's not really a
right answer here's one what do you miss
about old youtube old youtube there's a
lot of relics a lot of throwbacks and
stuff i do miss that back in the day you
can be a little bit more edgier i do
yeah i think like you know it would be
cool to see someone see if like um
i don't know like um
a million legos could like stop a bear
for the gal or something like that like
whereas i feel like videos like that
like that aren't necessarily bad but
just because it has a gun like i don't
feel like the times have changed yeah
for sure exactly i kind of there's also
like ui things like i look at a
screenshot of old youtube and i
immediately like think of the videos i
was watching back then i don't know if
you have that like oh this was the era
of the ray william johnson same yeah ray
william johnson call of duty
commentaries like woody's camera tag and
all those guys we're running out of
places
we're uh we're in front of a dumpster
yeah for this next one uh we're joined
by this dumpster here so uh there's a
lot of space inside and outside for a
lot of people working on a lot of
different things yep
how many people are on the team
currently do you have to ballpark
something like that i mean that's top
secret information we'll just say that
it's been
going up quite a bit i mean obviously we
went from videos back in the day where
it was just me and chris and we would
just react to stuff to now you know with
squid game we had to build eight full
hollywood level production sets and yeah
i mean on that video alone we probably
had 300 different people working on it
like at least 150 just contractors alone
building stuff you know
20 editors 20
plus camera people stuff like that so um
i mean they're getting pretty huge yeah
there's a lot that goes into it but
thankfully we have this dumpster to film
in front of
all right in 30 seconds or less
we've had team trees yeah it was an
incredible success yeah it's still going
why should the internet care about team
c's well i mean if you care about the
ocean you should care about team seas
because basically for every dollar we
raise the ocean conservancy and ocean
cleanup have agreed to remove one pound
of trash or plastic from the ocean and
we're trying to remove 30 million pounds
of trash or plastic from the ocean
before the end of the year and i know i
sound like a salesman but like i mean i
don't know why would you not care it's a
pretty great pitch though yeah exactly
but also at the same time like it's not
the end-all be-all it's not going to fix
all our issues i think it's just a way
to show that you know the younger
generation cares and we want to make a
change and like you know these little
things add up right yes this one thing
might not you know make a huge dent but
if 100 of them happen and inspires
people to build new technology or to use
you know metal whatever water bottles
and stuff plastic water bowls it all
adds up so it's really just about you
know making a little dent and inspiring
the younger generation to do good
perfect it's not necessarily about the
30 million pounds it's about the
inspiration it's about the positive net
influence of people coming together and
demonstrating something powerful so yeah
and just showing that people care
honestly honest thoughts on youtube
rewind
should they bring it back
is it retired forever yeah how do you
feel about real definitely retired
forever should not bring back the thing
is youtube's massive right like dude
there's a giant community that speaks
spanish there's a giant community and
even like
southeast asia and like there's so many
different communities on youtube that
you have never heard of none of them
have ever heard of because we speak
english we don't speak their language
like i think back in the day it was
perfect because it was there you know
when smosh did 10 million there wasn't
many channels with 10 million right it
was a different era but i think
youtube's gotten so ginormous that it is
impossible that i think you should do a
rewind for tech i think whatever like
someone in the beauty community should
do a rewind for the beauty community and
i think like that's what should happen
it should it should definitely just get
passed down to the creators to represent
their own communities because they know
it better than anyone all right jimmy
last question oh boy what's the best
advice you've ever gotten the best
advice
he just hit me i thought we were gonna
switch places um
i think
one thing that i like that helped me
is uh you're
you're crazy until you're successful
then you're a genius
and i think for a lot of people when you
know you're grinding as a small channel
people think you're too obsessed you're
a weirdo stop only making videos like
get alive be realistic you're you know i
mean people will convince you you're out
of your mind for wanting to to do this
but then once you're successful they're
like yo your drive your tenacity was
great but it's like yeah well where was
that back then you know i didn't get
that when i was a small channel and so i
think you're crazy until you're
successful then you're a genius
and with it
keep it up if you're if you're a creator
watching this which i feel like there's
going to be some of them out there like
if you want to take any inspiration from
this video that's kind of part of it
number one make videos that you'd want
to watch that's for me number two make
the best videos you possibly can and
eventually that's a great thing to
aspire to anyway
and then keep at it
thanks for watching
catch you guys later can we do this
peace oh i beat them